okay so today we're going to follow a
little ball
about uh this item about mel and about
real programming
what i should have said at the very
start is that uh these techniques of
real programming and
real programming is in quotes here is
really very bad it will get you fired
from most companies these days
because most people
could probably write these programs but
they're very very difficult to
understand
and read back and that includes yourself
about two weeks after you've written the
program
it's almost impossible to work out what
you've done without
scratching your head and as most
commercial programs are read many more
times than they're written
it's important they're understandable
and not
taking liberties with them by doing
these strange tricks
so today i want to talk about one of the
second
tools in the armor of the real
programmer in this case mel
and again not something you should ever
do because uh i'll explain why but
there's various
disasters that are waiting for you so
this one is about self
modifying code so what is self-modifying
code
it's a program that can change itself so
it program will just go through
executing instructions in memory but
there's perhaps no restriction
necessarily on the fact that you may go
and change those instructions
so whilst you run through your
instructions the first time the program
may go and change those instructions
so eventually the program looks nothing
like what it started out as
so why might you do this there are a
couple of
possible reasons why you might do this
and they're almost always in very
strange and weird
conditions so typically you should never
do this
so the first case is when you're
in very constrained environments and
this may be such as booting up a
computer
typically on a computer boot you are
allowed to read a few instructions from
either the disk or a cd or a
memory stick or something like that you
you'll get just a few bytes read in
by the operating environment and
you have to do something with those few
bytes to load in the next section
so this is what's known as bootstrapping
often this will
include overwriting the instructions
you're
currently running to write a program
that will load in the rest of the
operating system so that's
a possible case not very common that you
will need to do this sort of thing
there are other occasions where you
might need to do it in very constrained
environments
if we go back to mel's story he he was a
wizard doing this sort of thing
the other main place that this is used
these days
also is a nefarious one which is
computer viruses
computer viruses often disguise
themselves by uh
creeping into your computer in some
encrypted form
and then decrypting their code and then
jumping into this decrypted code
so even you if you get a copy of the
virus you can't work out what it's doing
until you manage to decrypt it
so this is just another way of hiding
things there are also things like trojan
horses that also rely on
corrupting memory and then jumping into
the middle of it and starting
instruction from there
so those are the two cases that i can
think of
where you might use it and one of them
is particularly nasty
reasons why you shouldn't do it the
first is it's almost impossible to debug
it's because you you start off with a
program on this side and your
running system here and very quickly
the running system bears no relation to
the program because it keeps getting
modified so
if you're trying to work out what's
going on this
starting code isn't really going to help
you because that no longer reflects
what's actually running on the machine
the second is that you may not be able
to do it at all
in fact modern operating systems
usually mark the code that is uh full of
instructions as read-only so you can
only read the instructions and execute
them
you can't actually go and change them
and this is
particularly because viruses have done
this thing of actually changing
code so if you restrict your
uh code sections of your program to
being read only
then you can't have a virus go and
change the program under your feet
so you may well not be able to do this
at all
particularly in modern operating systems
they protect you from doing that
and third problem is that modern
computers again for efficiency reasons
they
they want to do things in the normal way
that
you would execute a program so part of
the execution environment is to
pull instructions from memory into a
cache so they're
local and ready to run and then they
start getting loaded into the cpu
and whilst the computer is executing one
instructions
it's already starting to decode the next
instruction and this is a whole pipeline
that is
getting ready so everything is in a sort
of a sequence
so that it's ready to execute
as fast as possible if you go and change
one of those instructions then you wipe
out
all this uh this work that it's done
if you go and change an instruction it
has to go and reload the cache because
it's now
changed uh if it's halfway through
decoding and instruction ready to
execute it it might have to
stop that so that this can stall all
sorts of
issues so that's another reason why
we're not
uh encouraged to do it so
with that let's go on and have a look at
some so let's just uh
to begin with have a look at a basic
program so this is
about the simplest hello world program i
could write
using no standard libraries or anything
just raw operating system calls and if
we
compile that and run it you can see
there
it produces hello world but what i was
interested in is
if we actually um dump out the binary of
this okay we have
dumped out what it actually contains and
you can see here it's disassembled it
and this is the actual program
won't worry too much about it but this
is the assembler
over here and this is the actual raw
binary
the instructions so 55 would be a push
register bp onto the stack but you can
see here really
what i'm trying to illustrate is that
these are just numbers here so there's a
55 here
48 and 89 and these are all hexadecimal
but it's quite possible for you to have
a program
that could instead of moving this
register from here to here
it could move a number from here to here
so we can change the 55 for a 48 or
whatever else so this is how you go
about writing a self-modifying program
that some of these instructions will go
and change the instructions that you've
actually
already written so that is why it gets
quite complicated
because this this program continually
changes
now we could actually go and write one
of those but
i'm not particularly good at assembly
language anyway so i thought instead
we'd
take a different world example programs
have been
described in various ways but one way is
equate it to a recipe
so here i've got a recipe for victoria
sponge i think it is
this is how you might lay out the
equivalent of a program
so recipes have quite well defined ways
of laying out now and most people
understand that and they know how to
interpret recipes
so typically you have a set of
ingredients here we've got
sugar butter eggs self-raising flour
baking powder and milk and then a set of
instructions with what to do with those
so you can think of this as almost the
data
and this is the instructions so you
follow the instructions through
and you end up with a cake now instead
we want to look at something a bit more
akin to the self
modifying program this would be
something a bit more like this so it
starts off looking a bit like
a regular program so we start with two
tablespoons of milk 140 grams of flour
one egg and one teaspoon of baking
powder
and we set the oven to 170 degrees and
grease is caked in
but then it gets a bit more complicated
because then it says if it's after 3 p.m
let's add 3 more eggs and 100 grams of
butter and 100 grams of sugar to the
ingredients
otherwise let's delete the baking powder
from the list of ingredients and add 180
milliliters of milk to the ingredients
and actually also turn up the oven by
the amount of flour divided by three
and then next if there is just one egg
swap the cake in for a muffin tin
otherwise add 60 grams of flour to the
ingredients
and then we have some more instructions
mix the last two ingredients add any
remaining eggs
add any remaining flour and so on and
cook for 10 minutes plus two times the
number of eggs used
now perhaps you can get a sense of this
that although it starts off as a
sort of regular recipe you actually got
no idea
really how much of any ingredients or
indeed what ingredients
you've got to use because it modifies
them as you go along
you've got an extra totally different
thing we've got butter here that isn't
actually mentioned here
we've got sugar that's not mentioned and
although it says one egg here we find
later on that
we need another three more eggs
so it's very difficult to work out what
this program is doing
and it's quite difficult to write this
program in the first place
and to get it to come out into something
sensible
but i think if i got it right this will
either make a victoria sandwich
or a yorkshire pudding so you can see
it's quite compact in that we have one
recipe that can produce two different
things but actually
it's a nightmare to actually understand
to work out what's going on here what
ingredients you need
what temperature the oven would be and
what it's going to produce
you don't know until you're actually
running through the program this would
not be a great recipe
to interpret it's much easier to go back
to the original
type of recipe which we all know and
love and this is
also true for programs if you follow the
sort of i'd say the recipe for doing a
program
that you you set out your data then you
run through the instructions and you
don't modify the instructions it's okay
to have
conditional parts in the instructions
but you don't go and modify them
then we all know where we are really so
just like this is the right way to write
a recipe
unless you can think of very strange
conditions you would not write a recipe
like this
even though it might be more compact and
you can get several recipes
all in one tiny four by ten card or
something like that
and then it would have to spin all the
way around here before it could pick up
the next instruction which was print b
and this
he could work out was enough time for
the that is a huge problem
if you go to a website you know you
don't see the ip address right on your
browser for example you just type in